quelle est la couleur de la neige et la
couleur de la crème chantilly du coton
que hbo la vache
si vous avez répondu du lait à cette
dernière question vous êtes tombé dans
le panneau et vous venez d'être victime
d'un effet d'amorçage
ah oui les vaches ça boit de l'eau en
fête l'amorçage ces camps d'une manière
ou d'une autre on vous met dans
certaines dispositions qui vont
influencer vos choix
ici le fait de vous faire penser de
façon répétée aux blancs à augmenter la
probabilité que vous répondiez du lait à
la question de ce que buvaient l'apache
l'amorçage fonctionne grâce à ce qu'on
appelle notre mémoire implicite qui tend
à faire automatiquement certaines
associations et on va voir que cette
mémoire implicite nous expose à des
formes de manipulation mais nous permet
aussi peut-être d'en savoir un peu plus
sur nous mêmes
[Musique]
il existe de nombreuses manières de
mettre en évidence les effets d'un
amorçage une des plus classiques c'est
l'exercice de complétion de mots
imaginez je vous présente les lettres
suivantes et que je vous demande de
compléter ce mot et bien si avant je
vous ai parlé de guerre de soldats de
mitrailleuses et là il est plus probable
que vous le compléter en char alors que
si je viens de vous parler de chiens ou
de souris vous allez plutôt le compléter
en chat ce que je vous présente avant de
vous demander de compléter un mot peut
vous amorcez c'est à dire préparer votre
cerveau à faire un choix plutôt qu'un
autre
il existe un autre exercice un peu
relier qui permet d'étudier de façon
quantitative ses effets d'amorçage
on l'appelle la reconnaissance lexical
le principe c'est que je vous présente
une série de lettres et vous avez deux
boutons l'un pour indiquer que ces
lettres forment un mot qui existe dans
la langue française et l'autre au
contraire pour répondre que ça n'est pas
un mot
si je vous présente les lettres
suivantes bas ça n'est pas un mot donc
vous appuyez à gauche alors que ces
lettres six ans forment un donc vous
appuyez à droite c'est facile comme je
le truc c'est qu'il faut aller le plus
vite possible
et moi je mesure votre temps de réaction
est ce qu'on constate c'est par exemple
que si avant l'exercice je vous ai parlé
de feuille de route forêt et bien au
cours du test vous serez plus rapide à
reconnaître que à rbr eux est
effectivement un mot la langue française
l'effet d'amorçage va se traduire par
une diminution du temps de réaction sur
les mots qui sont associés alors là vous
allez me dire tout ça n'est ni très
surprenant ni très inquiétant si je vous
parle de forêt évidemment votre cerveau
est préparé à entendre parler d'arbres
et donc il va plus vite à reconnaître ce
mot quand on est présente et d'ailleurs
des chercheurs ont pu montrer par des
analyses irm le mécanisme cérébrale qui
est derrière tout ça si on réalise un
amorçage et bien ça conduit à une
réduction de l'activité cérébrale dans
certaines zones qui seraient normalement
impliqués dans la réponse en gros
l'amorçage fait que notre cerveau se
concentre sur certaines choses et en mai
d'autres de côté ce qui lui permet de
gagner du temps dans les décisions
et tout ça est finalement plutôt logique
et rassurant notre cerveau optimise son
fonctionnement de manière avec le plus
rapide et le plus pertinent possible
sauf que ça peut conduire à influencer
notre comportement sans qu'on s'en rende
compte
en 1996 le psychologue john bargues a
réalisé une petite série d'expériences
étonnante sur les effets d'amorçage
il a convié des gens à faire un test ont
leurs affiches et des séries de cinq
mots par exemple trouve le il
le cash instantanément et il devait à
chaque fois formé une phrase de 4 mo
parmi ces cinq qu'ils soient
grammaticalement correct par exemple ici
il le trouve instantanément on leur
faisait faire ça sur trente groupes de
mots et puis à la fin où les remercier
de leur participation aux tests
sauf que ça n'était pas ça le test ça
c'était juste les préliminaires
en réalité on avait divisés au hasard
les participants en deux groupes l'un
des deux groupes avaient dans les
problèmes auquel il était soumis des
mots du genre anciens sages retraités
reid des mots en rapport avec la
vieillesse
l'autre groupe était un groupe de
contrôle dont les mots étaient
quelconque du genre voiture propre soif
et c'est seulement une fois l'épreuve
terminée que le test commençait vraiment
à la fin de l'exercice les participants
devaient en effet apporté leurs
résultats à un chercheur situé dans une
autre pièce est il sans qu'ils le
sachent qu'on chronométrer le temps
qu'ils mettaient à traverser le couloir
pour s'y rendre
est-ce qu'on entrait les chercheurs
c'est que les participants qui avaient
été amorcées avec des mots liés au
concept de vieillesse mettaient plus de
temps que les autres à aller d'un bout à
l'autre du couloir comme si le fait
d'avoir pensé à tous ces maux
ralentissez leur marche
alors certes on peut dire que la
différence était réelle mais quand même
pas énorme mais les chercheurs ont fait
une deuxième expérience sur le même
schéma avec des résultats plus tranché
cette fois cette fois les participants
étaient divisés en trois groupes un
groupe qui faisait l'exercice avec des
mots en rapport avec la politesse des
mots comme cordialement apprécié respect
ou courtois un second groupe qui à
l'opposé recevait des mots comme
agressivité intrusion impoli et enfin un
troisième groupe de contrôle avec des
mots neutre et cette fois le scénario
était un petit peu différent les
participants avaient toujours comme
instruction d'aller apporter leurs
résultats à un autre chercheur mais
cette fois il y avait une petite mise en
scène au moment où le test se terminait
et bien le chercheur censé collecter les
résultats étaient en fait en grande
discussion avec un autre individu qui
était en fait un complice et ce qui
était mesurée c'est si les participants
allaient osé interrompre la conversation
pour pouvoir les remettre leurs
résultats et la mise en scène du raid 10
minutes c'est à dire que si
n'interrompait pas vers les participants
pouvaient passer 10 minutes à poireauter
en attendant sagement que la
conversation se termine ce qu ont
ensuite fait les chercheurs c'est qu'ils
ont comparé la proportion de gens qui
avaient choisi d'interrompre la
conversation en fonction des trois
groupes qu'ils avaient constitué parmi
les gens qui n'avaient pas été amorcées
38% ont été un terreau
pour la discussion avant la fin chez
ceux ayant été amorcé avec des mots
évoquant la politesse c'est seulement
18% et par contre dans le groupe de ceux
qui avaient été amorcées avec des mots
en rapport avec l'agressivité ou
l'impolitesse le pourcentage est monté à
62 %
l'interprétation des auteurs c'est que
l'amorçage amis les participants dans
des dispositions les conduisant à être
plus ou moins agressif ou polis dans les
interactions sociales et à la fin ça
fait quand même un sacré effet quelques
années plus tard bargach réaliser une
autre expérience tout aussi surprenante
il a demandé à des gens de venir
participer à une soi-disant étude
concernant des coussins thermique qui
peuvent produire du chaud et du froid et
qu'on utilise parfois pour soigner des
douleurs musculaires
la moitié des participants devaient
manipuler brièvement un coussin qui
produisait du show et l'autre moitié le
coussin produisait du froid on leur
demandait de simplement donner leurs
impressions et puis on les remercier
d'avoir participé à l'étude en leur
proposant une petite récompense comme
récompense on leur donnait le choix
entre deux objets mais présentées
différemment
l'un a été proposé comme étant pour le
participant lui-même et l'autre
accompagnée d'une mention du genre pour
faire plaisir à un ami
et les chercheurs ont regardé si le fait
d'avoir tenu le pacs chaud ou froid
avait une influence sur le choix de
récompenses et ça n'a pas raté
ceux qui avaient tenu le pacs show ont
choisi à 54% le cadeau présenté comme
étant pour un ami et à 46% le cadeau
présenté pour eux tandis que dans le
groupe froid et bien les proportions
étaient de 25 % seulement pour un ami et
75% pour soi la conclusion qu'en tire
les auteurs c'est que la chaleur
physique peut avoir un effet d'amorçage
sur la chaleur sociale
du coup si vous voulez draguer allez
plutôt aux sonaca la patinoire
[Musique]
en 1998 trois chercheurs ont eu l'idée
d'utiliser ces phénomènes de mémoire
implicite non pas pour influencer le
comportement des gens et pour essayer de
révéler des choses sur leurs opinions
profonde
ils ont créé ce qu'on appelle le test
d'associations implicite à roissy le
principe
imaginez que je vous donne deux boutons
1 dans votre main gauche un dans votre
main droite et que je vous présente
successivement 30 mo en vous disant si
c'est un nom de fleur vous appuyez à
droite et si c'est un insecte vous
appuyez à gauche donc tulipes à droite
rose droite gates gauche mussig gauche
etc et il faut répondre le plus vite
possible parce qu'on mesure votre temps
de réaction
c'est par un exercice très difficile et
les temps de réaction se trouve en
moyenne entre 550 et 600 millisecondes
maintenant on va faire le même exercice
avec des mots ayant une connotation
soient positifs soient négatives pour
les mots positifs
vous appuyez à droite et pour les mots
négatifs à gauche par exemple si je vous
montre amour à droite désastre gauche
prison gauche cadeau droite
et c est dans ce cas là les temps de
réaction moyen sont à peu près les mêmes
qu'avec les fleurs et les insectes
bon maintenant on va compliquer et on va
mélanger les deux exercices
c'est à dire qu'on peut voir apparaître
des mots qui sont soit positif soit
négatif soit des insectes soit des
fleurs il faudra appuyer à droite quand
ce sont des mots positifs ou des fleurs
et à gauche quand ce sont des mots
négatifs ou des insectes donc cafard
gauche gentillesse droite
jacinthe droite meurtre gauche etc
or l'exercice paraît un tout petit peu
plus compliqué mais en fait les tendres
actions sont très similaires autour de 6
100 millisecondes
maintenant on va faire une dernière
variante qui va être comme la précédente
mais cette fois on va croiser les
catégories c'est à dire qu'on vous
demande d'appuyer à droite pour les mots
négatifs et pour les fleurs et à gauche
pour les mots positifs et pour les
insectes donc plaisir gauche frelons
gauche orchidées droite agonie droite et
c est avec ses instructions et temps de
réaction sont significativement plus
long 8 140 millisecondes en moyenne est
ce que vous voyez pourquoi dans notre
tête on associe plutôt les fleurs à des
choses plaisantes alors que les insectes
ont un côté plutôt déplaisant
donc quand on nous demande de trier à
droite les fleurs et les mots plaisant
et à gauche les insectes et les mots
et plaisant ça nous paraît facile mais
quand celle inverse on a plus de mal
on a des difficultés à associer les
fleurs et les mots déplaisant et
associer les insectes avec les moues
plaisant donc les temps de réaction sont
allongés ce que permet de mesurer ce
test c'est le degré d'associations
implicite qu'on peut faire entre des
familles de concept est une des
premières choses auxquelles les auteurs
ont pensé avec ce test c'est de
l'utiliser pour voir jusqu'à quel point
on peut être implicitement raciste pour
ça ils ont réalisé des tests
d'associations implicite en utilisant à
nouveau des mots positifs ou négatifs
d'une part et de l'autre des prénoms et
les prénoms étaient tous types et soit
plutôt blanc genre shannon adam hélène
soit type et noir
aïcha djamel jasmin le test se passe aux
etats-unis h précises et les
participants étaient tous de jeunes
américains blancs et là les auteurs ont
pu mesurer que pour associer les prénoms
blanc avec le positif et les prénoms
noir avec le négatif les temps de
réaction était autour de 7 100
millisecondes
mais que dans l'autre sens il était de 9
100 millisecondes
en moyenne c'est à dire que les
participants étaient plus rapides quand
il s'agissait de classe et jamel avec
prison et paul avec honnêteté
quand il fallait faire l' inverse ce qui
est intéressant avec ce test c'est pas
tellement de montrer que le racisme
existe bon ça malheureusement on le
savait déjà mais c'est qu'ils révèlent
les préjugés d'une manière plus profonde
que ce qu'on peut montrer avec des tests
classiques d'habitude pour évaluer
quantitativement le degré de racisme
d'une personne on lui fait passer un
test où elle doit noter des affirmations
du genre la diversité culturelle est un
problème pour notre pays
ou encore on voit trop de noirs à la
télévision avec à chaque fois des choix
du genre d'accord pas d'accord tout à
fait d'accord etc
c'est ce qu'on appelle un test explicite
ce qu'ont montré les auteurs c'est que
le test d'associations implicite révélé
didier raciste même chez ceux qui ne
ressortait pas spécialement comme
raciste dans les tests explicite si ça
vous intéresse de faire le test sachez
que les auteurs ont mis en place un site
web qui va vous permettre de le faire et
les résultats risquent de vous
surprendre
alors est ce qu on serait tous
implicitement raciste
alors rassurez vous non il faut faire un
peu attention aux interprétations de ce
test
la première chose à savoir c'est qu'il a
une assez forte variabilité intrinsèque
c'est à dire que si vous ne passiez
plusieurs fois vous pourriez obtenir un
score assez différent d'une fois sur
l'autre
il faut donc considérer les résultats au
niveau statistique d'un groupe et pas
juste d'un individu en clair ce test
n'est pas un diagnostic pour savoir si
vous spécifiquement vous êtes raciste
l'autre point essentiel c'est que les
chercheurs se sont rendu compte que même
par exemple chez les noirs américains
on pouvait retrouver des personnes qui
d'après le test avait un billet contre
les noirs ce qui est quand même un peu
étonnant
la critique de ce test a notamment été
fait par d'autres scientifiques dans un
article intitulé est-ce que jesse
jackson aurait échoué aux tests
d'associations implicite jesse jackson
c'est un pasteur noir américain qui
était militant pour les droits civiques
un disciple de martin luther king et qui
un jour a déclaré je vais vous traduire
approximativement il n'y a rien de plus
douloureux pour moi à cette étape de ma
vie que de marcher dans la rue
d'entendre n'est pas derrière moi de
penser à un voleur puis de regarder de
voir que c'est un blanc et de me sentir
rassurés bref ce qu'estime certains
chercheurs c'est que le test
d'associations implicite ne mesure pas
tant le niveau de racisme d'une personne
que son degré de familiarité avec les
préjugés et les stéréotypes racistes
ce serait donc plus une mesure
d'exposition à un contexte social
raciste qu'un indicateur individuel de
racisme un point qui tend à confirmer
cette interprétation c'est que très peu
d'études ont été capables de mettre en
évidence un lien entre le score au test
d'associations implicite et le fait de
se comporter effectivement de façon
raciste et donc ça paraît un peu exagéré
de dire de quelqu'un qu'il aurait des
préjugés racistes
si ça ne se traduit jamais dans les
faits dans ses paroles ou dans ses actes
malgré tout il ya une étude qui a été
publié très récemment et qui tend à
montrer que certains de ses effets assez
subtil peuvent exister
l'étude s'est déroulée dans les
supermarchés d'une enseigne de grande
distribution française et l'idée c'était
d'étudier comment la performance des
caissiers et des caissières d'origine
nord africaine ou subsaharienne pouvait
être affectés par les éventuels biais
raciste de leur manager pour cela les
chercheurs ont collecté des données sur
34 magasins ça concernait la performance
de plus de 200 employés donc par exemple
leur vitesse pour scanner ou leur taux
d'absentéisme et pendant le même temps
ils ont fait passer le test
d'associations implicite à leurs
managers
il ya un point de méthodologie est
essentielle en fait chaque jour les
employés seront affectés aléatoirement
aux managers
donc ça représente
des tas de combinaisons possibles pour
lesquels on a pu mesurer la performance
d'un jour sur l'autre et ce qui a été
montré c'est que les jours où les
employés tombé sur un manager ayant des
préjugés racistes et bien leurs
performances baissait ça peut paraître
un peu évident comme conclusion mais là
où l'étude devient extrêmement
intéressante c'est qui s'avère que cette
baisse de performance n'est pas liée à
une forme de racisme explicite les
caissiers les questions ne se plaignait
pas d'attitudes racistes de la part des
managers et il avait même tendance à
moins se souvenir des managers qui
apparaissaient comme les plus biaisée
d'après le test
l'interprétation des auteurs c'est que
les préjugés racistes implicite des
managers les conduisaient simplement à -
interagir avec les employés d'origine
nord africaine ou sub saharienne et que
c'est ça qui conduisait à une baisse de
leurs performances donc il faut être
prudent même les billets implicite peut
avoir des conséquences si ces questions
vous intéresse je vous encourage à aller
lire le billet de blog qui accompagne
cette vidéo dans lequel je donne des
détails sur cette étude qui fait quand
même 57 pages qui est très documenté et
qui me semble très solide
méthodologiquement merci d'avoir suivi
la vidéo n'hésitez pas à partager vous
abonner mettre des trucs bleus tout ça
les actualités de la chaîne c'est sur
facebook et sur twitter et ceux qui le
souhaitent peuvent venir soutenir sur
technique merci à bientôt
[Musique]
il